a business here at home is
the singer
Oi Marcos
and I only have Horizon 1
Andthere
And
there Gabi is
Andthere
Hello everyone, it is now located at
Andthen
the police pass you ok
Andthere
the father baile funk e
e Rodas
the next one I'm going to need it anyway
series
A football Brazil
à la carte with things
and builds if you forget it can
be our award from Parque Cidade Porto
Andthen
the goal in Senhora da Graça in
the pants he only  testing done
Andthere
the artist from Maranhão to define
pays me
Andthere
and it is necessary
in 1832 strangers right
Good morning
Andthen
the end of the road just this not so you
remember that
the ticket for the week will have to
be in this  At the moment I'm the
Hey Hey
HeyHey
and not sure cheap advertising